The island of Bali lies in the center of the Indonesian archipelago...
...between the islands of Java and Lombok.
But to the Balinese people,...
...their island is considered the center of the spiritual universe.
Bali has a population of around four million people...
...and is home to Indonesia's Hindu population.
The Balinese practice the concept of Tri Hita Karana,...
...which seeks to balance the human, natural and spirit worlds.
And it is this sense of harmony which makes Bali more than just a physical destination,...
...but a complete state of mind.
Most first-time visitors are drawn to the south of Bali,...
...a region blessed with incredible beaches and world-class surf.